sorry I was getting into that song
nothing you saved Jiu-Jitsu for me today
I just hope you know that you saved
Jiu-Jitsu for me why cuz I like I know
we talked about it a podcast or two
ago but there's nothing I've wanted to
do more since I started kettle bells
than to quit
Jiu-Jitsu and I I I I know why people
like it and I can see that it's great
but I
just I'm terrible and I go to get beat
up and it's just it was had a hard time
so I was really and once we started
kettle bells I was just loving that so I
like I'm to quit you did to because
nobody's beating you up no one no well
you beat me up but so we we went I
wasn't even going to go today I was
going to go later and then you said you
had an early one and like I I I got it
today like I I still don't love it but
I've always how must have just sweat a
ton was your T-shirt sweat was your ghee
wet everything you were there for an
hour and you were on the floor for 30
minutes we were yeah but we were there K
and then we did five or six sets of
kettle bells you did the best work
workout you've done in a year because
you mix cardio and you me mix a little
strength training and you mix good
cardio pushing a fat [__] off
you well I mean it was a hard workout
but that's not why I mean I've had
harder workouts at other jiu-jitsu
classes it's amazing how much and this
goes for everything how much the the
person teaching you or the person you're
listening to affects something it's kind
of like how like with like religion how
like there's crazy preachers and there's
normal preachers and then good podcast H
and bad podcast
H I've had good teachers with jiu-jitsu
but I like it's why I click with yogi
Steve I really I I dug what what John
was saying and it was a small I I don't
do well when there's a lot of people
like I need I I'm terrible I need a
little bit more focused attention and I
it just it was great and I I it was
something that I think I could do from
now on like neon cuz that's what I was
told since I have such short [__]
arms like T-Rex arms that I'm going to
be better on top so neon belly just I
was like what is this like I it's
something I can actually kind of do and
it's I don't have to wrap my arms around
somebody everybody jiujitsu yeah there's
people that do it with no [__] legs
yeah because you still it's a great
exercise I'm [__] lazy I was scared
the first year I used to go once a week
I used to put my ghee on and not go
really I wanted to do that put my G on
get in the car drive and go around the
corner and go home and tell my wife some
story how it started already and I felt
embarrassed going in and then you know
how bad I'd feel about myself you know
how bad I felt about not going why and I
go in there and see 16 people in there
because I felt worse not going than what
I felt going like the embarrassment of
not being able to breathe and not doing
the hip escapes everybody else is doing
and not being able to do all that [__]
that's a form of embarrassment but the
form of embarrassment of not showing up
at all and not trying
that's the worst feeling I ever get
whether I cancel a gig when I don't do
something I'm supposed to do I feel
horrible about myself what does it feel
like like I [__] failed because I was
supposed to do something period that's
it period there's no two ways about it
you know uh we all I remember I joined
uh when I was a kid I went to karate
religiously there wasn't nothing I went
right from school walked to karate and
met yeah cuz there's 5 days a week
Monday through Friday and then Saturdays
and the only way I knew to get better
and to learn because what do you want
you want personal attention you're not
going to be able to walk into any place
and wait till the class is over and go
yo teach can you help me with this but
if the teacher sees you raising your
hands and Confused during the classroom
on the way out if he's a good [__]
teacher if he has not another class
coming in he'll sit with you for 10
minutes and break it down for you
anybody who sees a human being trying
and doesn't help him is not a human
being right and I don't need a one on
one private but it was it was like there
were like three people there I think
including me and the and then four for
the teacher and it was just a little
like I I'm I'm I'm not the kid who
always asks questions in class like when
you're supposed to leave but something
like this I feel bad I try to I try to
not to but I ask a thousand because I
don't know anything about it thousand
questions then you got to go home and
get on YouTube right there that Nick
Gregorius there's a there's a couple
people that take Jiu-Jitsu to the
beginning and you'll put Jiu-Jitsu is
like everything else it's like a [__]
it's like a chef okay you know what man
lee [__] podcasting [__] [__]
standup comedy [__] all this nonsense
I'm going become a
chef okay so I go to Valley College I
sign up for the chef program okay okay
they teach me how to make a chocolate
cake right a certain chocolate pie I'm
just making something something up here
let's say apple pie I love apple pie I'm
a fat [__] I love eating apple pie and I
want to make the best apple pie in the
world okay they're going to teach me how
to make a best apple pie but then I'm
going to go to your mother's house with
Thanksgiving and your mother's going to
give me a piece of her apple pie and I'm
going to pull her aside and go what the
[__] you putting here and then I'm going
to start stealing her recipe and then
I'm going to go to somebody else's house
and they're going to turn me on to some
other apple pie and I'm going to go
what's in here and eventually I'm going
to learn how to put it all together
right and that's what happens with
jiu-jitsu I learn a little bit from
Eddie Bravo I learn a little bit from
salami I learn a little bit from Nick
Gregorius I learn a little bit from uh
Joe whatever his name is the big uh
Gracie the the the guy that's in London
the big tall guy I watched him and my
whole game changed because I realized
you're in no rush that's my biggest
problem right now what's the yeah
everybody everybody who's new because I
see was [__] cuz you see them doing
it so easily or it looks so easy and you
like I just I I just always try to do it
all right away but that's the biggest
thing you're starting from the beginning
the way you would start start from the
beginning of anything right I bet there
were days at 6:00 in that other [__]
office when we were in your house you
didn't like podcasting you dreaded going
in there cuz there's Growing Pains
there's growing pains and everything no
matter how much I dig you if I got a
restaurant I go come in I'm going to
teach you from scratch what do you think
you're going to get behind the line and
learn how to cook chicken for your
antino no I'm going to make you wash
dishes for two weeks then I'm going to
make you come in early one day and learn
how to make the Su cheef learn how to
make the sauces and how to prep cook cut
the onions and cut and you're going to
go Joey uh what the [__] you like to me
you didn't you told me you're going to
teach me how to [__] cook I'm
teaching you how to cook dog but you
want me to overcome everything oversee
all the little things that you really
need that you really need trust me if I
don't teach you how to cut an onion when
we get 200 deep how you're going to cut
an onion right cut some onions for a few
weeks learn from these guys then I'm
going to move you up a little on and
you're going to learn how to put chicken
breast on the grill and steaks on the
grill and then little by little I'll
teach you how to put it all together
same thing and this is what I was it the
same when you were growing up that it
just like cuz I feel like I don't know
if it's movies or our parents or
whatever it is but I when I when I came
out here I knew you know you know you're
going to have to start out at the bottom
but I just think you don't know what the
bottom is like say oh I'm going to go
Apprentice at a at a restaurant you know
you're going to have to do some things
but after 6 months that when you're
there at midnight scraping pans you're
like what am I doing this for but what
is but like I understand why why you do
it but it's was that something that was
like I felt like it's a newer thing but
is it I didn't know going on forever
sacrifice has always been something in
every [__] body's life to get to that
place where they need to be you got to
sacrifice something and and some of us
are very lucky but no matter what you're
going to do [__] they're going to make
you do [__] that somebody else doesn't
need to do oh yeah no but did they do
that did PE did people know that when
you're growing up or I feel
likeu years I think people don't know
now well listen listen people know but
they don't want to know right how many
times have you uh when you were 16 you
bumped into somebody a baseball player
whatever man how many years did you play
in the minor leagues if he tells you
eight you're like e right what' you do
for eight I can't do [__] E we never
could think we could do the time to to
learn to be something I'm surprised that
when we're 18 we even go to college
because it's a fouryear commitment it's
huge a lot of people don't like there's
a thing now to do like a leap a gap year
I guess is the word and it's the problem
is is I like at least for me I was so
ready to to get going I would never if
like you couldn't have convinced me of
that if you if you gave me a million
dollars but looking back on it it would
like it does seem smart to go at least
for a year if not a couple but it just I
I feel like there's a lot of pressure to
go to a good when I come you and I go
Lee you got two options you got three
options you ready you could either go
work you go to College full-time got it
you could go work for your uncle at the
car
dealership or you could go to college or
you go to service right all fouryear
programs all foure programs because let
me tell you something yeah you're going
to make money in the car business after
90 days you're going to make money I
made money in my first month but do you
really know it you're going to go into a
transition period where you think you
know everything and then you're going to
realize that you were way better off
when you were stupid because you didn't
know anything and people believe when
you tell them I don't know that answer
but we'll find out inside let me ask you
this what would it take for you to drive
this home well what's the air pressure
on the tires I have no idea I'll find
that out inside but let me ask you this
what would it take to take that car home
well what's the capacity of the trunk
again I'm pretty new here I just started
yesterday and you've been there a year
and a half I started yesterday I don't
know nothing but let's go inside and
we'll get the information is that you
following me you're going right back you
gotta [__] learn
everything I know I wouldn't want I
would never want to walk into anything
and somebody say you're a chef and
there's people that have been training
for six years they're going to despise
me and number two they're going to show
me up because they've been doing this
right you got to start in the bottom
with
everything when I when I [__] started
comedy the reason why I got into the
comy at the time was because I had done
everything already there was nothing I
wanted to do I laid tile I asked made a
roof I bartended I [__] laid brick I
[__] built scaffold I quit when we
got to the third floor cuz I was scared
of heights I've done it all I've quit
more [__] jobs than you can imagine I
was your typical [__] loser that was
going to end up at Subway sandwich when
I was 50 you know because I [__]
around I always was looking for that
answer there's no answer the answer is
you want to really cover your ass you
work hard you get to know something and
then you you could take your chances
because no matter what you know
something if I if if tomorrow Mercy was
10 and I bring Mercy in here to [__]
[__] around with this computer and do
the podcasting and fix the microphones
when she's 18 she's going to be cases
Morris yeah she's going to know
everything about this without even
knowing but that's but see that's also
the point so Casas Morris has been doing
this for six years whatever 10 years
when he gets here he's going to have to
start at the bottom and that's what I
think is talk about not really kind of
though at least not really that 8 years
did something that eight years put
cashes Morris in the middle level listen
if I would have came here when I first
started comedy or when I came here at
the six year mark with six years to come
to our life for a guy like me that was
very too soon cuz I was far from being
ready to move to LA as a comedian wow
really but when I came here because I
did the triple runs and I hosted that
triple and I just something I knew 30%
of the people which made my journey a
little easier I knew Doug Stan hope to
get me into the store I knew uh James
Stevens III I knew Josh Wolf I had
friends down here me doing comedy before
edged me into some rooms I saw people go
oh [__] I remember you from Seattle come
on go up ninth you following me oh right
no he'll definitely go ahead fast cuz
people after a week people will be wait
you're 18 and you're doing this right
but they blow so much smoke up your ass
in college about how great this school
is and how how how great of an education
you're getting so when you leave College
you're like [__] I'm I don't want to be
a mail room guy I'm I have all this
great expensive education now don't
don't be a mail room guy and see how
fast you get your head handed to you
years to but it's what I say to youal
that if I would have stayed at vmac if I
would have said [__] this the podcast
stays at 6:00 a.m. and every Monday
whenn place a show and every Friday when
I'm in town just through those two days
I'm I'm going to go to marcelo's class
because he does Tire throwing he does
all that [__] we do in Kettle class at
the end of the beginning of class to get
you tired so when you do Jiu-Jitsu and
you learn Jiu-Jitsu you learn how to do
it from technique not strength so you're
not jumping on people you're not tackl
him you learn how to do everything with
finesse and then it gives you muscle
memory and the next time you're in that
position so that's why he ties you out
first to get your muscles tied so when
you do Jiu-Jitsu you learn how to do
technique I've heard about if I would
have stayed in that class right now I
would have been walking around at
2:45 you think so I know
so I would have been the first time I
walked into vmac if I would have but
things happened I still stuck with
jiu-jitsu but I just didn't take his
classes they were 8:00 by 8:00 I really
have no energy by 8:00 I have energy to
do a regular class but by 8:00 I don't
have the energy to do the jumping jacks
the burpees and then a regular class I'm
not going to lie to anybody here I'm
just going to hurt myself somewhere
along the line it's a late class my
focus is a little gone I've already
smoked 18 joints my mind has been raced
through ideas I'm burnt out right at
8:00 I got a set left left because I
bump into people and they make me
talk do you know what I'm saying that
gives you energy that gives me energy
absolutely that's why I talk before I go
on stage to people that's a little put
the air on brother there is on full
blast yeah holy [__] it's [__] getting
hotter this edi's kicking in Jack either
or something Good's going to happen I'm
kind of cold yeah that's why when I go
to those when I go to those places I
want to have human contact 10 15 minutes
before I go on stage a certain human
contact not let's take a picture and let
me no no no no I want to have some a
conversation with a peer or a friend
that I know and maybe get into a slight
argument about something that'll really
put me do you ever pick arguments like
just when you about to go on stage
absolutely really absolutely that's
hysterical I used to always yell at Joe
and Brian for having matching
phones like what would you say what the
[__] is wrong with you [__]
look at you you're like two [__]
girls and Joe would know he wouldn't
take the bait red man would go why is he
yelling is he crazy we didn't even start
this fight and Joe would go watch what's
going to happen b boom and he'd go I
didn't get it for him to [__] do well
he's got to get a little pissed off at
something stupid shoes some of these
shoes somebody's haircut you know like I
in the back of my mind I I I say that
it's bringing me bad luck like why you
wearing that shirt dog you giveing me
bad luck before and you're like sitting
there like feeling bad I don't want
anybody to feel bad if I Tau you before
I go on stage it's just something I do
to get me fired up like you had to wear
those [__] shoes tonight you had to
wear those [__] shoes today you know
even like if you came to a show with
Paul after you made those things yeah I
did what are those classes the Crepes
Crepes I destroy you like you came here
with [__] Crepes get the [__] out of
here did but then you ate them but then
I ate them that's right after I got on
stage you brought me the cheese one and
[__] that's [__] that's interesting I
have to I have to bite my I have to get
a little fired up about something do you
have like any other specific people like
it sometimes is it's just the [__]
color of the wall in the room I'll just
start yelling if I'm alone in a room I
just start going what the [__] is your
problem oh no I didn't but I meant like
is there like someone at the who's
always at the store who just you would
always go after or just like beat up for
like Bob how you used to mess with Bobby
Slayton could be anybody it could be
somebody wearing slippers it could be a
woman with a mini skirt I'll ask her
what the [__] she's thinking it's 10:00
at night there's rapist out there what
the [__] and still look at me like what
are you saying to me why are you saying
these things to me because I'm just
getting fired up to go on stage if not
that's when I get
anxiety oh if you don't get fired up if
I don't get fired up the anxiety wins
that's where the anxiety comes from I
end up winning that the anger ends up
beating the anxiety eventually the
anxiety just drills me to get angry is
that what you feel on stage angry [__]
yes not angry but I'm I'm venting I'm
letting this anxiety out of my body
there's a brain fart that happens before
I go on stage it's the week's event
sitting in the back brewing and every
plus the anger I had growing up so every
week I let a little more out you know
what I'm saying like every week a little
bit more comes up so I'm giggling on
stage I know you're telling jokes so
you're trying to be funny yes but are
you happy or like is it like you're
yelling at like your wife but she's not
even there happy I'm happy but I have to
go to a certain place to make that joke
work when you go to Judy Carter's
workbook again I know you [__]
I'm going to break my balls [__] you
Joey who's Judy Carter again she has her
worksheet in there and she writes down
this is very interesting because I I
guys this is why the beginning is so
important because you might look at
something in the beginning of any career
that's so stupid but in the middle after
it get doesn't it get and it doesn't get
explained to you you figure it on your
own and you go oh now I get why I have
to put my foot there [__] you know [__]
do I feel like a [__] jerk off that's
why I don't question none just shut your
[__] mouth put that thing put that
[__] finger there do it now roll oh
how bad was that and you feel like a
[__] jerk off so the same thing when
you look at that Judy cter workbook she
gives your exercises to do and there's
one of them that after I realized the
exercise I do it all the time you ready
go for it 10 things you [__] hate hit
me with the first one if I had to tell
you in a list from 1 to 10 what's the
number one [__] thing you hate okay
what do you hate the
most I don't care broccoli people who
cut you off yeah I was people who Park
like [__] that bothers you that's
the number one thing in your life that
bothers you the most you just said
broccoli was an example I don't know
broccoli is like number eight I don't
[__] know
[__] yeah sure that's all that's for for
right now understand me so if I gave you
a tape recorder yeah and shut my mouth
and said I want you to give me all the
reasons why you hate when Joey tortures
you about watching TV what's in his
business what I do it's [__] Friday
night I'm with my girlfriend I'm [__]
relaxing I went to the gym four times
that right there if you say that on St
AG that's what they want to hear have
you been bugging this office no I just
know so do you understand they don't
want to hear I really hate peas and my
pork fried rice because you don't it's
something that bothers you but you still
[__] eat it I'm talking about when
you think about it you get [__] angry
what is it Lee when people don't take
your [__] cool and it's get and the
reason the the thing that makes it the
funniest is that we all have something
that bothers us that come on get over
yourself it should not bother us it has
nothing to do with our lives but at one
time in our Al we let it go into that
special dark place and now every time we
think and it could be somebody cutting
you off Le's been in the car with me I
don't care what you do in a car just do
me a favor have common sense we're not
even talking about being smart here I
don't care what your IQ is having an IQ
and Common Sense two different [__]
worlds common sense is you know people
are going to go around me why I double
parked in the [__] left lane what
kind of [__] human being am I let me
pull over you know little things you
know what I want to finger my girlfriend
let me get a parking spot instead of
double parking and slowing people
there's little things that you could
talk about that you just hey you go to a
restaurant and the [__] waiter ask
you three time you know and it really
bugs you but you can't blow up it just
takes you to like six before you start
yelling and then you cool off on your
own that's it that thing that you would
if you went on stage and said [__]
Joey de [__] him and his [__] no
watching TV I work hard all week I go to
the thing I [__] Paul my this I clean I
do the office I want to go home and
watch Nine episodes the [__] whatever
I want and people are like what the [__]
is he talking about all sudden they
start laughing from your energy because
it's it's yes it's the words that come
out of your mouth but it's also the
[__] energy how you're saying it it's
not what you say it's how you say it Lee
you know what you're a Jew [__]
Nazi [__] Jesus should have burnt you in
that [__] Camp okay we just laughed
we just [__] left we're all extremely
high but you ready yes you know what Lee
you're a miserable Jew [__] I hope
[__] Hitler should have burn your
whole [__] family right there that's
an offensive thing but if I said
leave someone save that for this when I
see you're a miserable [__] Julie and
Hitler should have burnt your whole
family it's two way are saying it that's
comedy and that's the things you learn
by doing open mics you're not going to
go up on stage because you read a Judy
Carter workbook or because Sarah Silman
talked to you you're not going to cut
you're not going to make that shortcut
and comedy not if you want to get into
the level and this is with anything
whether you play the piano whether you
play the drums well Buddy Rich taught me
how to play the I don't give a [__] you
still got to play 12 hours a day you get
Paul McCarthy you get all those great
guitarists and you pull them into a room
in different rooms and you interview
them and you put your their mother in
the [__] room and you tell them tell
them how long you rehearsed and the moms
will say he was to get home at 3: eat a
sandwich and go into the garage till
dinner time do homework and then go back
out there till
11: that's all he did right that's I
mean that's all you did that's all you
have to do but then how do you feel as a
comic who's put in 20 years and did that
work but then there are people who can
skip the line and even though they even
though they're not going to be as good
they still they're still working like
there's still clubs who are going to
hire the line somewhere along the line
they're going
to
do it you know what I'm saying like I
haven't seen Bill bur get pushed I don't
work with Bill bur enough
right Sebastian because he's a comedy
store coming but Joe Rogan wants to open
up in a hole that's why I open for Joe
Rogan all those years that's his
discipline and that's what makes a
killer comedian they want to start in
the
minus anybody could start on the 35 yard
line Joe Rogan wants to start on minus
20 and drive down the field down your
[__] throat so when he shoves that
touchdown down your throat you're going
to laugh the way you did at the end of
that joke last week when you were
giggling when he was on top of the
[__] bar stool
there's few comedians that could handle
that type of ego check I could handle it
I do it all the [__] time I bombed
what people don't know is I bombed 50%
of the time and all these last night I
ate dick really yeah at Jim Florentine
that room down there I a [__] dick I
tried you know I just talked it was 35
people but I showed up I did try
something I wanted to try and I went
home that was the the the the comparison
you know what I'm saying I don't mind
being in a hole I've had to follow Joe
Rogan for the last [__] month at the
commi store you're in a
hole and the first time that I had to do
it it threw me off a little bit but
after that I came back with a vengeance
because I went home and I thought about
it most people would have called in sick
or canceled their spot after that I look
forward to it now because it's going to
make me a better comic on the road I
don't like I've worked with a thousand
comedians who are going to R remain
nameless that will not work with heat in
front of them to make themselves look
better I think that's a flaw there's
tons of comics who will [__] in their
writer will will put that they don't
want to work with a dirty comic in the
middle or somebody very funny they don't
want to do it bro last year I worked
with a cat in Michigan that was blowing
me out of the water every night some
skinny cat from Chicago that's loud and
crazy like me and I went up there and
finished the job but but if I didn't
have The Comedy Store Marine training I
had he would have killed me every night
he would have killed me every night he
was that strong most people would have
had that kid fired or switched around or
told to to switch his jokes up most
people would go back home that night and
call the club the next morning and say
Hey I want him to remove this joke this
joke this joke anything not to make that
guy funny if I told you guys the names
of the comedians that did that to me you
guys would [__] your [__] pants you
guys would [__] your pants that's why
when you see a cat like Joe Rogan or Ari
shafir or Duncan Trussell or even a
little [__] guy from Columbus Ohio
called redband cuz Red Band will go
after me every [__] night go up to
redband and go redband who do you want
to follow Joy Diz he doesn't care if he
bombs because he knows he knows that
he's going to bomb 10 times and then for
every 10 times that he follows me he's
going to do good one time then two times
then three times then four times then
five times and and guess what Joey D is
going to have a hard time following that
[__] and that's the way life is
you don't want to follow punks you want
to look at the baddest dude in the room
and say I want to follow him and you got
to take that's the
discipline that's the discipline that's
the discipline Jiu-Jitsu teaches you
that today when I was on top of you Lee
I could have taken your [__]
life at that moment but I didn't and you
know I could take your life now it makes
you a tougher person that's why I'm
telling you if you're going to sit in
this town and do the goals you want to
hit and the things you want to do you're
going to go to Jiu-Jitsu twice a week
cuz you're going to be a winner if you
do this because at 27 by the time you're
35 they can't stop and you're going to
see everything coming at you and the
discipline you have from Jiu-Jitsu is
going to carry over into your personal
life which means at 801 because you're a
[__] Jew from the old country you're
going to be with a pen and a piece of
paper figuring out somebody's career
somebody's next special that's what a
manager does they don't wait for [__] to
come to them they get up and go you know
what what can I do for my client how am
I going to wake my client up with good
news
today you think there's that much
correlation between Jiu-Jitsu and your
personal life I know why do you think I
have stayed with jiu-jitsu for the last
two years because it's help my
comedy how long did it take you to see a
difference 90 days really everything
flew together I started Jiu-Jitsu 6
months before I went back to the comy
store I started jiu-jitsu
May of no like a year before I went back
to the comedy store I went back to The
Comedy Store in August of
2014 okay I started
jiujitsu in May of
2013 wow so more than a year but it all
started coming together because I know
to get better for me to I was going to
quit Jiu-Jitsu I couldn't breathe I went
to that place I went to [__] Dr B's
hypnotherapist oh yeah for the side
whatever yeah and then I went for the
[__] uh I went to this clinic for $35
they were supposed to hypnotize me to
give me better oxygen it didn't work it
didn't stick the guy told me to come
back for 18 sessions I told him to shove
that up his [__] ass and I said you
know what and then Dave presented an
opportunity to me so I started going
Jiu-Jitsu with him and I'd be
embarrassed as [__] dog first six or
seven times we didn't even roll he just
worked on my hips taught me how to move
better on the floor how to switch my
legs how to trap people's legs with your
foot
and then January he started making me
roll with him it was brutal he's [__]
long-legged I couldn't pass his guard he
would choke me he would throw me up in
the [__] air you think I wanted to go
see that guy are you [__] kidding me
and I had to pay
him who pays to get that torture but I
knew that if I stuck with it if I stuck
with it it would help everything else in
my life it let me realize how easy it is
to take my [__] life how somebody
could take my life on the street
you know makes you think about that I
haven't thought about that yet you think
about that I was on top of you today you
were turning purple really if if if if I
was an evil person I could have started
choking you I could have broken your
neck I could have done it I could have
sucked your dick pass made you pass out
and suck your dick and took a picture of
you I could have done thousand things to
you you know what I'm
saying maybe I shouldn't go to Jiu-Jitsu
anymore no that's the point that you're
leaving there alive every day and you're
getting stronger not your muscles but
your will everything around you and this
is the same if you went to simple karate
Le if you went to karate and there was
this one little white dude that was 15
and when you sparred every day kick you
in the stomach and he kicked you in your
little chubby stomach and your stomach
will go after he kicked you you wouldn't
want to go after three days in a row
specific yeah after three days in a row
you wouldn't want to [__] go back to
karate right because he keeps kicking
now when a 15-year-old kiing my butt but
you're going to go you know what I'm
going to go back to figure out why he
gets that kick in and then one day
you're going to figure out how he gets
going to start blocking and then one day
you're going to figure out how to
counter it how to block it and punch him
in the [__] nose so next time he
throws that kick he keeps his [__]
hand down these are all things but they
wouldn't happen unless you show the [__]
up I don't bro do you think I knew this
at 26 I didn't know this guar was 30
[__] five because remember I started
comedy at like 31 or something but I
would didn't get S I thought it was like
[__] once a
month and the rest don't come to me on
stage it don't come to you trust me it
don't come to you unless you work on it
you're not going to [__] go to
Jiu-Jitsu the third time and throw arm
bars on [__] oh cuz I seen Rich
Franklin do it no you didn't you're not
you know what I'm saying right you're
going to try but they're going to figure
out a hole because you didn't see all
this in the [__] YouTube video
they'll always leave something out it's
like an Italian mother with her sauce
they'll give you the recipe but they
always leave something out so they
always got you you know what I'm saying
what the [__] you think you're dealing
with here some novice kakaka I love that
episode of Everybody Loves Raymond which
one where uh Ray's mom puts a wrong the
wrong label over of spice and gives it
to Deborah with her sauce recipe I told
you but then it's terrible I told you
nobody gives you the right recipe they
give you everything except one thing so
they always got you by the thin [__]
fies you think you're dealing with [__]
how you feeling I'm feeling good man I'm
feeling good so you're very excited it's
the beginning you and 80 other milon
Americans are very excited I
congratulate you I know how excited you
are what have I what have I done
football that's it when working hard
summer [__] went through focus on the
team [__] June you went in you had no
quarterback for first four games and
then now look at you now you got a
quarterback starting what game do they
suspending him whatever one he chooses
no he's not suspended not at all not
even one game no Tom's focused on on
beating the Pittsburgh Steelers and
having a good season what's the line I
have no idea what the [__] how don't you
not look where they playing uh they're
playing in New England and it's raining
oh [__] let's
see we're always remember when we used
to do them on Sunday and we picked every
single wrong that's it I don't want to
even [__] talk about why got to throw
[__] SL my wounds for okay um the
over and under is 55 and New England is
favored by 6 and a half God damn or it's
seven at some places God it's [__]
eight in New
England probably yeah it's eight in New
England 7 and A2 and eight in New
England what's
55 that's a lot of points I don't know
but well cuz raining so there's not
going to be good passing [__] that's
what they're [__] setting you up with
[__]
licker maybe but we don't have we have
we have good tight ends but we don't
have very many receivers this year what
would you do if this [__] went
out tonight yeah and threw four
touchdowns I'd pee my pants that' be the
best do you think he could do it tonight
[__] yeah okay he could do it just to so
28 points right there Point that's 28
they put up 21 the Steelers they got a
good offense yeah that's close to
Rothenberg is 150s fatter than me
now hold on one
second I leave you a message yesterday
what's up
everybody you know I love you co suck
I'm just teasing you you're on the
podcast live you know I love you
talk I love you with all my heart where
you at this
weekend he's are you vacationing or
jumping up and down or cracking
jokes like I said you're pimping it big
on the message I left you forget all
about the your Cubans that's it you're a
big shot now you're in Honolulu you got
the wife with
you how many months is she
pregnant 6 months would you please tell
her to call me I want to get on the
podcast before she bust a nut
please this is the third [__] time I
got to tell you please I don't want to
disrespect
you all right thank you sir call me when
you get back from Honolulu I miss you
[__] all right be good be safe
down
there all right bye I think we should
leave that in so people can hear what
you're like on the phone I don't give a
[__] you can leave it in I want people
to know what I'm like on the phone I
called him two days ago he calls me back
now but he's in halulu it's a 10-hour
flight you know whatever the [__] what
were we talking about a football season
oh yeah so yeah listen after the tough
summer I mean right now America's
looking at this game like if you live in
New England right now you're betting
this game you're betting New England and
the [__] under you think so
it's raining you just told me yourself
it's raining well I did but then you
said they could that you just said they
could throw 50 like nothing 55 yeah what
would it break down it break down to
thir
35 16 35 20 that's 55 and they got to
throw five [__]
touchdowns I don't know if that'll
happen I and you know I read part of
that article
yesterday I hope it's not all true cuz
if it gets really hard to like like I'm
always going to like him I'm from Boston
that cheat [__] but it's
American what do you want me to tell you
listen what's the thing in UFC uh the
the now it's the [__] IV before that
it was the steroids right you know with
football it's the [__] with the
listen New England Patriots have always
belich has always been a [__] some
sort of cheater and I guarante T so was
Parcels I think and and here's the it's
not you can't justify like to say
everyone's doing
it that still that doesn't make it right
but I feel like it is happening but the
part that I just [__] figured out was
belich was terrible in Cleveland and
that now all of a sudden he's doing
great I love that he's doing great but
it's what were the allegations like they
would send people into the other the
locker room to get the list of the first
20 plays they were going to run that
they had a whole secret like bat cave
with with all like notes on coaches and
teams and their and their signals and
like they'd go the week before and and
tape all their
signals which wasn't illegal to till 06
I think but then it's probably ille
illegal because of us or because that's
happening they've been doing that for 30
[__] that's what S Lawrence did yeah
and see that's my that's what Ty
Lawrence did for Big Time colleges right
he basically was a consultant to tell
you how to play that team but basically
he went there with [__] uh pedophile
binoculars and uh you know and a camera
and and and a notebook and a piece of
paper and wrote down everything I think
the issue is it's kind of like the weed
dispensaries that get closed around here
it's the ones that are getting too
successful and making too much noise the
Patriots won all the time and with by
like
landslides and so that's that's probably
going to that could have pissed people
off or I don't I don't know what the
issue is but listen where there smoke
there's fire oh yeah they've already
been nationally caught twice and I'm not
even mad at him like I believe in
football I believe in all this [__]
because I know when it gets to that
amount of billions of dollars you always
need an edge when you're playing that
level of life that picture you tweeted
of with Robert Craft and the judge you
know I'm not lying to you people when I
tell you that that this prior
relationships there's money that guy and
he tricked everybody I don't even I
didn't even read the article about New
York or how he got that case in New York
but that's Jew [__] that's topnotch
Murray call this guy call Sai and tell
Sai to talk to the judge and see if he
could put that case in New York to trick
everybody no New York judge is going to
overturn who gots he's like the king of
the of the American Jews we one of them
listen man that that level of money you
you spend a lot of money you know and
here's the funny thing with that level
of money I guarantee they have a budget
for cheating [__] you and they call it
something else operations or uh what's
what's the word uh uh when an economist
comes in and analyzes statistics they
have to call it something if Consulting
if you look on their payroll if you look
through everything with a microscope and
sit them down there's $800,000 a year to
go to somebody who goes to Chicago and
takes pictures not the week before the
year before and the year before that
that's all he does is count the [__]
intelligence to keep it at that level of
sports you'd be an [__] not you'd be
an [__] n and I guarantee I'm not
saying Robert cph was involved I'm never
saying that but I'm saying if you think
belich I don't know what the article
said I think everyone's involved it's
just it's uh [__] I had a point what the
[__] do I what were you just talking
about New England Patriots and now I'm
not mad and I'm not even thinking about
it because as big a fish to fry in my
life but the whole situation I was like
it made me think about the Ray Rice
thing about how they said that like no
they they hadn't got it at the NFL
office they have all these investigators
going and they have all they definitely
like for Anytime they and then they had
this thing with Mike Marts where they
made him release a statement saying the
league did a good job and then they even
doctored his statement that they made
him make so I don't leave any of them
anymore that's in their corporations and
they have to do what they have to do
speaking of Corporations something funny
happened the other day I got home the
other morning I went somewhere I was
running around you know it's been 10
[__] 10 here all week so uh by my
house it's tough to park in the
afternoon so I got to walk a long way
wherever the [__] I was I had a walk I
had like a suit on I don't know where
the [__] I went Monday and I went home
took off the suit hung it up and just
sat on the couch and watch air
conditioner for two or three 3 minutes
just to sit in the air conditioner and I
was scrolling through to see what was on
it's 1 in the afternoon when the [__] do
I watch TV at 1 in the afternoon and
office and a gentleman was on you've
never seen this movie I have not now as
a kid I I said it before I hated Richard
Gear [__] hate him because every girl
liked Richard Gear I'm like who's this
skinny little [__] weasel and you
know what I'm saying he did American
jiga and I went you have the grud
against Richard Gear oh my god when I
was 18 I hated Rich gear I hated any guy
that was good looking like that and [__]
cuz they interfered in my [__]
sabotage work I already had problems I'm
not a handsome dude so I got a [__]
Sling from the left and now I got a
[__] now I got Richard Gear [__]
[__] my world up at the movie theater
with these Freaks and [__] so I took
this girl to the Mayfair to watch that
[__] American jiggle on and that he
walks around with no pants on I was
doomed I was doomed I was looking to
finger her something it was winter time
once she saw her ass and my ass there
was no [__] comparison I was like
[__] this this ain't going to [__]
work I hated [__] Richard Gear
then offic in a gentleman came out and
it was like this big [__] movie and I
still refused to go see [__] Richard
Gear like [__] you [__] but then in '
85 things got bad for me you know I I
had just stopped doing blow I was clean
like maybe [__] four weeks I'm hiding
I'm living in [__] I'm living in
[__] creskill New
Jersey and
I'm working in the city as a bartender
at 5:00 in the afternoon so I would go
into I was jonesing for weed then I
didn't do blow but I love Mar that's
when I fell in love with marijuana when
I was healing in ' 85 like I just gone
through five years of Vietnam and here I
was living in Cresco I had no
communication with none of my friends
none of them except maybe Loops nobody
else knew where I was cuz I didn't want
them
lying now R skill is basically 25 mi
from North Bergen 30 Mi you know here I
am like nothing like nobody's looking
for me like
nothing and I uh go into the city it's
cold as [__] I I got to I get high I get
a dime bag of weed or whatever the [__]
it was a nickel bag and I'm walking on
uh on 181st Street and Austin I see
double feature thief of
hearts and American jiggle I'm like
Jesus [__] Christ I'll just see thief
of Hearts you know who thief of Hearts
had in it who your buddy who sat in this
chair a couple months ago Steven bow oh
[__] all right so that was Steven Bow's
first mistake remember he was sitting
here going that uh how this and that the
movies he [__] died with this one
that was his first Doom after Scarface
he turns down Top Gun but he signs on
for this movie with some scottchad where
they rob him and the Red Dog him and the
guy from uh what's the scottchad you
know like a [__] like a [__] [__]
right right him and this [__] him and
the Red Dog what's red dog's name uh
Nick Tor calls him Red Dog from Miami
CSI oh okay I'll look it up that [__]
guy we're in this movie where they play
thieves and they break into this guy's
house some [__] mormo over there with
glasses like some artist
type uh David Caruso David Caruso this
is 1984 people I'm dropping some serious
movie [__] knowledge on
you it's [__] 10 it's got to be 10°
though the the the the winds are coming
off the Hudson
Le coming off the [__]
Hudson I walk into the movie theater
it's probably 10 after 1 I watch sta
hearts with Steven Bower Dave Caruso
some other guy and some chick I'm dying
this movie is [__] terrible but what
are my options I'm going to walk out in
that dead of window with no friends
[__] no I said you know what this was
bad how bad could offic in and gentleman
be and I'm sitting there Le not at this
time Lee I was not talking to my stepdad
i' gone to war with my uncle the people
my family in Miami was mad at me 90% of
North Bergen was mad at
me I was homeless I had just had a place
to stay in
Cresco I just was building up my esteem
like was I wasn't snort and blow I was
just getting to be at 50% who the [__] I
was was as a man you know like like I
would sit there and go what happened to
this piece of time what happened I was
just
lost and I'm met this movie theater
watching this [__] dude and he joins
the Air Force and uh the guy from scarf
faces in the movies okay they got me
he's the
father and boom Dave Caruso's and that
uh a bunch of people office and a
gentleman that [__] Oki from wisi
dude the chick from Trading Places but
that's how she got trading uh Beverly
Hills Cop that's how she got it this was
with this movie and this chick with big
tits I mean and I'm watching this
[__] movie in De Winger and I'm
watching this movie about this goodl
looking and Richard Gear has got a crew
cut and that [__] is still
slinging dick if you watch office in a
gentleman put it on with your girlfriend
even with a crew cut he's still slinging
dick you look at him going oh I think I
would suck his dick at a gay bar with a
couple qus in me I don't even need Cosby
there right he is [__] handsome as
[__] with his [__] little white
little [__] navy suit on whatever the
[__] he's got on I don't know what I'm
hearing right let me break it down for
you I'm breaking it [__] down for you
now at the timely let's face it I'm a
[__] punk of a [__] thief
Hustler I'm using credit cards to eat
under $50 what does that tell you that
means I would eat the scab off your
elbow and rub it on my steak you know
what I'm saying like I'm a [__] dirty
[__] and that's what he plays he plays a
guy that gets a guy to buy [__] shoes
for him and belt buckles and he sells it
to people and he makes 10% off the top
and he's just a hustler he knows how to
steal he knows how to work the [__]
system to his advantage and I'm looking
at this movie and I'm like okay I'm not
Richard gear but this is who I am just
some guy and he joins the this thing to
hide all I was doing when I got to La I
was buying but I didn't even know this
back then guys but at this time in my
life in 1985 I'm just buying timely for
what just buying timely I'm 22 years old
I have no [__] family I have no
career I have no life I have no
education I got three semesters in the
college in Colorado Colorado Mountain
College that just [__] good as I
might as well go to [__] uh it it and
join the [__] entertain payment
[__] division whatever the [__] it is
you know I got nothing Le I got no money
put away what I had on my feet the
clothes I had and a couple sets of
clothes is what I had Le Duff bag why
why had you come back from Colorado at
this point because I thought there was
something going on in New Jersey and
what I walked into was Hell on Wheels I
I walked into February of 84 everybody's
coked up everybody's got Coke for sale
and everybody's [__] fronting it and
I tried for like 3 months I stayed on my
[__] good and narrow but you know
what you can only work for 10 bucks an
hour for so long you see your friends
dropping [__] hundreds at a bar
you're sitting there with [__] you
know bunny rabbit is and and a frown
you're working 60 hours a week trying to
be a good guy and your friends are
dropping thousands out of bar every week
you know how long does it take before
you buy into the American dream and say
[__] it let me get an eight ball of coke
and see what all the fusses about that's
what happened Le and I got myself into
tons of trouble but here I am at this
[__] movie theater
in January of 85 I'm just starting to
get my self-esteem back and they catch
him selling those belt buckles and the
guy tells him now you got to
quit and he goes I ain't
quit and he says something I tweeted
what he said I'm sitting there on the
couch and I'm remembering this time in
my life in 1985 when I had nothing going
on now I'm looking at Harry and Demi and
I'm looking at Mercy Mercy was a school
or some [__] I think people thought you
were having like a breakdown was having
a breakdown that's what I'm trying to
say so I started did you see what I
wrote I wrote something about uh let we
go find it no it's old it's gone uh I
could quit but I know you could [__]
break me but I won't quit and then he
gets down on the floor and he [__]
well he's doing pushups and he goes why
are you putting up with this and he goes
I've changed he goes no you didn't
change you just polished up the edges a
little bit you're still the same and he
breaks him down he's like your mama was
a [__] Aly your father was a [__]
ho chaser said don't you eyeball me and
Richard Gear would eyeball him don't you
[__] eyeball me [__] keep
doing those push-ups and he would make
him do push-ups with his face going into
the mud and then lift up then he would
have to wipe his face and he just broke
him down and he goes you could quit I'm
getting rid of you and he goes I ain't
[__] quitting and he goes quit and
that's when he gets
up and he
goes I got nowhere else to
go and he just starts yelling at late he
just starts yelling I got nowhere else
to go I got nowhere else to go and then
life takes a beat and he goes I got
[__] nothing Lee I never wanted to
kill myself more than at that time in my
life when I was 22 years old because
that's exactly what I was going through
I sat there in this
movie just holding my head going how the
[__] does this movie know what the [__]
I'm going through
inside and guess what I did
what I watched the movie got up I called
my job and I said I can't come in I'm
sick and I sat there and I watched the
movie all over again I didn't leave that
movie theater till 10:00 at night it was
[__] freezing when I walked out of
there I had had a nervous breakdown I
sat there and watched that thief of
Hearts piece of [__] and I didn't even
know what was going on I just sat there
trying to figure out how this [__]
black dude knew what I was going through
like in my I I just felt
horribly and then he ends up staying and
they win the war and he's a hero he
leaves with Deborah Winger but it
doesn't matter he yeah oh it's
tremendous the guy kills himself his
buddy someone got mad at me because we
give a season six spoiler of The
Sopranos and the thing is I get mad too
but Joey you're the worst spoiler in the
whole world but this Show's been out for
years they going be crazy if I got mad
at you listen
listen you [__] Momos all right
office the gentl is 30 years old if you
ever seen it shoot yourself you got no
[__] taste in movies I'm over here
crying like a [__] Momo and you're
over here trying to tell me I'm
spoilers the [__] is
wrong you're G to get some G about
season six of The Sopranos the show's
been off the air for eight years if you
haven't seen that show I'm embarrassed
I'm embarrassed for you
anyway what the [__] is your problem C
sucker I don't have a problem what are
you doing tomorrow going to your show
that's at night what are you doing
tomorrow morning oh I have no idea
working out you to come with you want to
come with me over to the 911 memorial go
over there and take some pictures to
loot the flag where's the 911 memorial
what's with the questions over here at
North Hollywood Park we'll go over
there hold on one second I got to take
this real quick excuse me if I knew this
is going to happen what's up
doctor
yo good sir talk
to
yeah hey Johnny B I'm in the middle of a
podcast
with
I want to be
around to pick up the
pieces when somebody breaks your
heart some somebody twice as
smart as
I
somebody that's my
doctor I got no clamidia finally went
away after 18
years really congratulations I'm lying
to you [__] I'm lying to
you I can't believe that you asked me
that question earlier about what
question uh was it
always about work ethic well no no no
not that was it always about work ethic
but I feel like I'm sorry not work ethic
but did you people expect the start in
the bottom yeah yeah like it always you
have to work but yeah I grew up with
families that that's what their families
did do you know what I'm saying like
when you let's say your dads were into
Building Homes that's what dick did you
and your brother like you didn't have a
choice if there's no money for college
we got a boat we got a house here we got
a house up in nck you want to go to
college there's no College say work with
dead and someday when I die you and
[__] your brother take over the
construction company do you think like
you go to the dinner table and go you
know I want freedom of speech and I want
to say in my career no no no you think
my friend vaneri that has that Under
Undertaker do you really think that he
told his dad I don't really want to work
with dead bodies is that what you think
as the male of the [__] house you had
no choice the [__] two sisters
involved in the funeral director what
that's how it was when I was growing up
the srino across the street from me he
had the boy and the girl the [__]
girl the boy still does the [__] work
50 [__] years later Lee you didn't
tell your father like no when you were
10 on Saturdays that's what you did you
went and worked with your dad and then
when you were 14 you realized that your
dad would pay you big money because you
were as good as the men he was going to
hire so by paying you 10 bucks an hour
when you were in high school which was a
huge amount when I was growing up I'm
sorry I'm I'm comparing that's like me
10 bucks an hour is still pretty good
let's say if I said to you listen Lee
what do you want Dad I want to be an
editor because Joey listen [__] you and
[__] Joey what's Joey giving you two
days a week I got 55 [__] hours I'll
give you 20 an hour for 40 and 30 an
hour for anything over [__] on
Saturdays and pretty soonly after a year
to when you're 16 or 17 guess who's
going to be running those Saturday
jobs Lisa
Junior so dad's going to say you know
what today I'm going to give you 30% of
the take which now you're in high school
Lee and it becomes maybe $1,200 for the
day let me ask you something when your
guidance counselor says to you so Mr
Sayad you scored well in the SATs have
you thought of any colleges and you look
at them and you flash your [__] ring
at them in high school and go listen you
[__] moo What do you you make a
[__] week 600 if you try with
insurance I'm pulling down 1,200 on a
Saturday what [__] College am I going
to I'm College I'm going to the College
of PR and cash and then your brother on
the other hand he's more of the reaching
out type you're going to fill a void and
your brother filled the void that's the
way it was when I was growing up like
right and everybody dug
trenches you know that's what your
parents did that's what you did there
just aren't really that many bus you
think like I said you think V went home
I don't want to work with dead people
they give me the yuckies what I will
punch your [__] mouth 50 times a day
get in there pick up that [__] stiff
and cut his ear
off but it's like cuz like sorry like
you or you or your wife don't have jobs
that you could pass down to Mercy so
it's like it seems like there's people
less of those kind of jobs to have most
people don't own their own
business in this day and
age I don't want you as my [__] best
friends that I love to death involved in
the job I want everybody to figure out a
a a gap in this [__] life that you
like and mix it with a business and do
it and pursue it because of not you're
not going to be happy I'm telling you
right now dog I tried I tried putting
money over happiness when I was [__]
listen when I went to work for my
in-laws when I got out of prison let's
be honest here he was paying me [__]
30 grand a year to start
which to some people like Joey 30 grand
wow how many Mercedes-Benz did you
[__] buy listen living in bould
everybody's paying eight bucks an hour
guys he was paying me 15 then he put it
up to 26 then to 35 once I started
generating you know D but what was my
point I don't even [__] know and but
I started on a roof I started making
more money I was cutting more [__]
roofs but then I had to figure out when
I lost that job I had to figure out a
gap and my buddy said that he had indoor
salesman but he never really had an
outdoor salesman we started talking and
I put that little gate together with the
[__] neon with Danny feebles I never
really wanted to have a job but I also
want you to start somewhere like if I
could do it all over again this is the
way I do it I do what you're doing right
now so by the time you're
30 you're making a guaranteed 80 grand a
year and you know all the [__] bases
already you're 30 now you could take
this direction wherever you want to Le
you're going to find the loophole in the
system and take this direction wherever
you want to like I told you maybe in a
month you're going to come to me and say
I'm done I don't want to do this no more
I want to do corporate corporate podcast
and you're going to go to niso and get
the CEO on the Brisco and the guy that's
in charge of advertising and pop out a
[__] podcast because it's cheaper for
them to advertise on the internet with a
podcast that will it be on TV which
nobody's watching anyway am I lying to
you no I was thinking about this the
other I'm giving you a free idea but
this takes two or three people this
takes getting on the phone calling
people up going down there and going
listen you're advertising and show this
is what you're spending you're spending
this number you know how many people
watching this this many you how many
people fast forward to the young people
wipe their ass with your [__]
commercial did you see they're going to
start putting commercials on Instagram
no 30 second commercials on
Instagram why why do you think Lee
because that's where the action is at
that's where and they L you in for a
while and it's free and there's no post
a picture of you [__] whacking off
yeah he gets 30,000 [__] hits 16,000
22,000 and it gets retweeted whatever
the [__] that is that goes out the
masses wa what do you think that these
people aren't going to figure it out
abisco these people Monsanto and don't
people attack them every week you think
have like a
Monsanto no not a Monsanto like a
podcast a picture of like a
GMO like like what sit there with
bulletproof [__] gear on and like
SWAT teams over them and they sit there
your friends at mon listen man why not
put yourself out there if you're a
corporation I got a beef with [__]
Apple let me [__] no I don't have a
beef with apple Lee I'm just saying I
got a beef with apple I'm just imagining
like the Samsung CEO like slamming like
[__] You Tim Cook yeah Lee this is where
the next move is going to go because
nobody's watching TV for ads what do I
have to lose as the CEO of [__] the
bisco or
FR you know if I was fruit aloom right
now I'm Sweating Bullets because
meundies is [__] their world up along
with 20,000 other underwear people if
Fruit of Loom was smart they come out
there and do a podcast every week and
advertise like these are the first
underwear you had on fruit of the
[__] Loom okay and then do the
podcast we make cotton with fresh cotton
nobody picks it we don't have slaves no
more we have machines they sell you the
[__] product during the [__]
podcast that's the future and I'm just
giving so I rather you pick a gap and go
work for somebody to work for [__] 30
years and sell your soul or whatever the
[__] you're doing maybe you're not
selling your soul but you're not really
doing what you wanted to do every job
you you've had as an editor right you've
gone home after the first month and
thought about a thousand ways to improve
that job on your own everybody does that
anybody who listens to this podcast will
get [__] drunk one night with their
sister and or their brother or their
girlfriend or their wives and telling
them about the [__] job they have and
how the the way they're doing it sucks
and how they would make it better and if
they had the money they would open up
their own [__] business everybody's
done that everybody's done that
including my [__] s we were talking
at Jitsu about Bad Bosses that we've had
before and I read an article the other
day that said that like the majority
like 80% of companies are hiring the
wrong people to be like the supervisors
and they're they're making the company
worse so and it's amazing how like you
don't even you don't even need those
people you could get rid of those people
and just have like you were talking
about the the sales manager at one of
your car dealerships oh how he cost you
money and like how if they just weren't
there so yeah everyone everyone's been
at a job well the problem is that these
high level people that these people have
a thing called an ego right and they
impose their ego you know because they
got to prove who every [__] job
you've had there's one guy with an ego I
started here 22 years ago as a burger
flipper and you know the guy's a [__]
Mora if he got fired from that [__]
job he had to you know he's the type of
guy that had to walk with the other kids
to remember where the school was at day
like his father had to put like a
[__] torch in front of the
house so he could get back home that's a
much of a [__] [__] he was when I
worked at Swift
Electric I moved back from uh Colorado
in 19 in February of ' 84 and like a
week later I went to my friend CT
Lorenzo's mother she worked in in the
union torches yeah pleas you got to put
a torch and the kid walks around the kid
walks around with a whistle with [__]
the fathers got pigeons they send them
out there to find the kids and [__] the
kids out there like a half a [__]
clapping get the [__] out of here all of
a sudden they got a job they've been
there because they got nowhere else to
go they put somebody together they and
what those type of people do is they
find somebody they put together they
really convince somebody that they're
the people for the job so you can't
knock them for doing that so I get to
[__] Jersey I'm there a weekly I need
a [__] job bad H yeah I go to my
friend's mom she's in the union she
knows some people and within 3 days she
goes go down to this place ask for this
guy tell him I sent you I went down
there fill out the paperwork Le the
Easter my starting salary was 200 bucks
a week 8 to 5 Monday through Friday and
7 to two on
Saturdays half hour lunch during the
week because I knew somebody you to get
in there you had had to start as a
helper in the truck okay but because I
knew Mrs D Mrs D got me in the warehouse
which meant that in 30 days I get in the
unit and it would cost me 200 bucks to
get in the international warehouseman's
unit and my salary would go from to $800
something dollars a week and I had to
pay dues and I got insurance and this
whole [__] thing I was off and
running 21 years old New York City ready
to rock 48th in Burger Line Avenue 43rd
something like that that on the [__]
Corner the guy that interviewed me was a
bad [__] good dude the guy that
Mr Swift the guy that owned the company
right was like a gangster like he was
cool as [__] and then he brought me into
this other guy named Anthony and he was
like a chubby dude a jovial [__] that
always ate and drank and his tie was
open you knew he was going to die like
he had a big redneck and [__] you knew
he was going to die soon and he go out
for lunch and come back lit Jack you
knew he was [__] lit this Anthony guy
he knew he was going to there was three
or four guys behind the counter that
were pretty badass cool as [__] to
communicate with in fact they threw a 20
or a 10 in your pocket from time to time
if you put an extra little something in
the [__] box for the delivery they
they gave you a piece of the action so I
started in the warehouse sweeping moving
[__]
boxes and there was this [__] guy in
that LE that just he had worked there
since he was
12 and now he was
40 oh all in the warehouse yeah and what
happened was that his friend was
supposed to get the next job and I got
the next
job you follow me so right away he
started breaking my balls was he your
boss or just yeah he ran the warehouse
so right away he would break my balls
every day about everything like come
here did I not tell you the [__]
shovel what are you an idiot shovel over
[__] here and he had a a Supra 1984
Supra that the owner had co-signed for
him and he would pull it up and wax it
every day and he wasn't a good-looking
guy guy at all that was the place let me
tell you how creepy that place was at
the time there was a truck driver
there it's so creepy it
ominous there was a this is 1984 ladies
and gentlemen let me tell you how open
this country was there was a guy there
that if you looked
at you could tell he either killed a
child and buried him
somewhere he had molested a little kid
molested a little girl he had done
something
inly he had a different energy to him
that's such I was no he was oh yeah this
guy was just black death right he was a
white dude he was a white dude like a a
guy from West New York I don't know what
nationality he was he was a white dude
and I forget what his name was but he
came over and shook my hand and he was
very nice and I would load his truck do
you follow that so they would give me
orders and I would load his truck there
were three trucks that I had a load load
okay and then I had to keep the
warehouse swep at the electric at the
electric play so I had to pick the wire
so then the other job I did was help the
people
who uh were in the the front counter
they would come out and S the 15 ft of
BMX wire or 10 ft of [__] pipe uh a
quarter inch pipe you know whatever the
plastic [__] for a pipe underground
whatever the [__] it was I forget all
the terminology now don't judge me you
don't know dick yes I do don't dick
in fact I even took a course in
residential wiring for 90 for you know
whatever 12 three credits at the
University of col that's how I got
involved in that and then I got hired as
an apprentice to work at Ashman electric
I worked for Ashman electric for a while
then I got hired by Jer electric then
like an [__] I went back to New
Jersey and left a great [__] job that
was Union the guy was in assign me into
electrical union we were get we were
waiting on my math grades from high
school cuz they wouldn't let you in the
union those days without your math
grades and your [__] high school
diploma how is your math grades H C's
but I took all preall [__] you know that
college pre-or nothing no no no [__]
Dewy Decimal systems none of that [__]
what is that in Geometry none of that
[__] I went as far as like algebra too
that's all you need so there's two
classes there no calculus I ain't going
I didn't take a calculus I went to the
University of Colorado and I dropped
that [__] three classes and
that was too much but anyway this guy
was a creepy dude and one day he he goes
dog you're going to have to help me
today because we I got a busy day and I
went on the truck with him and he goes
listen on the way back I got to stop my
house and get lunch you mind I was like
no it's [__] he goes my wife is there
she'll be downstairs I'm just going to
take the too dish you get to meet my
wife I pull up his wife was 15 years
old what he was like 35 to
40 he didn't have white hair yet but he
was going bald already so he could have
been like like 38 were they was she look
did she look young or was she actually
15 she was
15 and she came out they hugged he gave
her a lunch and he got in the truck and
I was [__] like I didn't know what to
say and then like a week later we did
the same thing I had to help him and he
brought me to his house again she said
hello if I was hungry they were very
nice
people and then one that ass mother the
warehouse and he was oh yeah he married
her when she was like 13 or something
he's had he bought her or something like
that no [__] idea why didn't anyone
report this this just like when we get
we get a nice lunch 1983 Lee people
don't know nothing 1984 you know she's
but the whole company knew he was
married to like a 15 or 16 year old girl
and what happened was he was with her
since she was like 14 or 13 but he
married her when she turned Le legal
like 16 he had been with her since she
was a kid parents knew everybody [__]
knew it was the C I didn't even want to
be in the truck with the [__] dude
but anyway back to the story that dude
that had been there for 20 years pretty
good meat balls oh my God it was
terrible that dude used to torment me
every day and one day I went [__] off
on him I already had the bartending job
at that time I felt bad I didn't think
they were going to findly me cuz Anthony
liked me and Mr Swift liked me and they
just said no no no they keep your job
they're going to give you a raise we're
just going to put you in a different
department we're going to put you in the
front but you just going to be in the
front you're just going to be that
number one guy going back and forth and
I think I lasted three weeks after that
by that time they had give me a raise to
maybe 420 something a week or something
I don't know what the [__] it
was it's [__] up when you have like a
boss who like every like I had this one
manager Legal Seafood whoo every time
she saw me I think she didn't like my
dad when my dad worked there maybe but
every time she like I ended up getting
like this I ended up getting fired from
there from like something crazy when I
fired I would just I guess quit I don't
know but it was just it's it's terrible
when there's someone there that makes
like when like when you said like there
were growing pains coming into
podcasting I used to hate like when you
would wake up and then you'd be like I
got to go to
work that's if that's that was my first
thought for all those years and I I
never I never felt that way about
podcast like that's why that's why I
think you're what you're saying is right
and you have to find like there's this
website someone told me about called
like you to me and you can people are on
there making like hundreds of thousands
of dollars selling online
courses so there's like ways to make
money online and do all that [__] so if
you hate where you're going I can waste
your time for 8 weeks you want to send
me money anything we've
discussed I could waste your time I
could write it up in the tablet and give
you a
course how about you just go out there
and put your both feet into it and you
learn so much valuable information dog I
ducked life till I was 30 Lee I'm
looking you straight in the face I
always thought there was a better
[__] pot of gold somewhere I had the
answer these [__] you worked
here how long 8 years and you still not
a m an assistant manager and you still
work Saturdays what the [__] is that
that's communist Cuba who works Saturday
eight [__] years I did everything
until I realized that there had to be
work involved and then I quit the
job I do everything I could until I
realized that after I was there 6 weeks
I wasn't moving forward this is what it
was for at least 3 years until they let
me move up and do the next job and then
it' be another two years till I became
became what I'm supposed to become and
then it take another 3 or 4 years to
really really get good at it to really
make money out it even if I was going to
stay as an electrician so that put me at
30 years old I would have had to be 30
to really start making 35 bucks an hour
but by that time you figure it out and
what do you do you open up your own
business I don't want to do commercial
[__] electrician I want to do
Residential
rewiring where you buy the house I come
in I rewire the whole [__] thing I fix
all the [__] boards I pipe it
whatever the [__] you need and I'm out
of there and this is a flat fee but now
you're competing about every you got a
bid different but you're doing it for
yourself and that's the most important
thing you make your own hours you get
your own pay and then everything falls
into place man you'd be surprised how
much work we all worry about if I make
the leap will work still [__] your work
will come your way because enthusiasm
breathes when you're hungry you sell
when I'm hungry dog I'll put it together
we'll put this podcasting [__] thing
together when you're hungry you know
what I'm saying you can do anything like
that in life when you're hungry so I
always want the person to get the
education I always remember one thing
somebody told me when I was 21 there was
a school for bodyguards in Aspen called
ESI ESI was executive security
information learn how to be James
Bond learn how to take a boat with
terrorists and karate chop them all with
the art of sink golden mayo and how to
how to how to take over a castle with
terrorists and knock them dead with
bullets and tear gas and grenades how to
how to take and I'm not lying to you
guys how to take over this how to take
over man hand-to hand combat all this
easy course would cost you $20,000
financing was available if qualified how
kind of them and also it was 6 week
course so in 6 weeks Le you're going to
teach me how to take over a f if I what
about what if I'm Lee Sayad and J Diaz
and one day we just wake up and go Lee
it's time we [__] take over we take
our country back of Israel and we wear
suits and yamakas and we [__] go out
there and take over little Villages like
some place that's small in Idaho and we
start hating black people in Puerto
Ricans but we like Germans cuz we B you
know something [__] crazy right and
uh what the [__] are we talking about
we're going to go to that six week
course yeah because in six weeks you
mean to tell me Lee I'm going to teach
you how to kill listen you know what
you're going to learn Lee you're going
to learn the motors the first time you
pull a gun out I'm going to tell you're
a [__] amateur and shoot you right in
the [__] head unless you had the
tenacity to kill from the start then you
know how to kill you learn how to kill
on the [__] streets you really do and
you learn how to defend people on the
streets but you you mean to tell me in 6
weeks if I give you $25,000 in my heart
earned [__] money you're going to
teach me how to how to subdue and kill
eight guys in the room with the deadly
art of ninjutsu art you developed in
Mexico while you were kidnapped and
tortured by these [__] villains let
me see this footage where's this [__]
footage and I'd see people go up there
dog every 6 weeks and sign up and then
somebody made it simple to me some guy
goes listen let's pretend you got $10
million and you got your family and some
guy comes into you are you going to hire
some guy that looks like [__] uh uh
what's his name uh you know tym chanm
with a gun to come in oh he just took
the six week course and how to [__]
defend or you going to hide a dude with
the missing eye in the twitch and he's
got like a rash on his neck from yellow
Army from Vietnam and on his resume just
has like amount of people he killed with
a [__] with a skull bone in it who
you going to hire dog skull bone
okay what are you going to tell chattam
tanum to go back and join the boy Scots
for [__] two years he didn't have the
patience all those people got taken not
one of those people got [__] hired I
guarantee you because I'd rather hire
somebody who was in the military for
four [__] years you know why because
he's heard a gun go off before a
thousand [__] times if you went to
Vietnam that's a [__] I don't care
a [__] if you're missing an arm that's
the [__] I want to my right if I
got a billion dollars and I'm Pablo
Escobar the guy with the missing on
that's gone through hell I don't want
the guy who looks like Tatam chanting
with a suit saying hello the people I
don't give a [__] what he looks like you
know what I'm saying and that's where we
all get taken everybody thinks you're
going to learn how to do something in
six [__] easy weeks get the [__] out
of here listen you want to learn how to
cook go to Red Onion go to one of those
places where they [__] get animals on
a daily basis and you got a Marin that's
how you learn how to cook at one of
those Taco Bell places anybody could
cook meat that tastes good get one of
those Billy Goats from the T that's
running that's running around marinate
one of those thing that's been out the
road get hit 20 times by a tire make it
taste like [__] the [__] that comes
in your [__] Taco that's the chef you
want to be anybody could get 100% meat
from Whole Foods and put onion salt and
make it taste delish let me see you get
a posum and sell it as [__] fet Manan
and [__] some white dude saying this is
the best fet Manan meanwhile they're
eating somebody's [__] somebody skunk
that [__] you would never eat skunk
no I wouldn't but got what do you know
what you're eating every time you eat
Thai
food what do you know what you're eating
when you go to [__] these taco places
and you don't know what the [__] you're
eating and you even told me you went to
[__] uh the place Paula likes the
Mexican place bow the death what's the
name of it you know the McDonald's place
that they sell Mexican food and WPS and
[__] Sebastian oh Chipotle yeah bowl of
debt that's what that is and you said
you looked at the brown meat raw like
cooked like uh in the thing Brown that
looks like it's got those bacteria
already on it you ever see when they
show somebody's stomach the bacteria
that's what that meat looks like I I've
never bro my wife likes it it drives me
crazy meat's really tough it's like it's
good in a burrito but the B I beg they
don't take Mercy there please do me that
favor it hurts my soul yeah let me do
some shout outs this is a good little
podcast I like I got stoned today we had
a good [__] time well how much do we
have talked about self-esteem what we
had a bunch we had like 200 milligram no
no we like 60 70 Mig no you long you had
you we split a a red Hornet what are you
talking about one packets we split that
right there no we split we each had our
own what are you talking about what you
there's no there was one now you're
making no now you're just now you're
just not telling the truth get the [__]
up you sound like one of those blowers
and [__] Don Wrangler Rory Oliva Timothy
Ward Jamie Uki spooky I love you thank
you for sticking up for meie spooky
we're going to get into that talking lir
security [__] I'll see you in two
weeks miss you [__] get ready to
eat 92 [__] stars you understand
we're going to make your left eye pop
out Lance Armstrong always good to see
you and my main [__] dude Aid
allias stop me if you can to Don
Wrangler yesterday did you my podcast
Don Wrangler is a good [__] dude he's
family Don Wrangler has been around
since Jesus left Chicago anybody could
show up and tell you they love you Don
Wrangler has been there through
battles he has been Jesus Christ what
you got planned for the weekend there
[__] nuts anything good you're looking
good I'm proud of you today you came to
Jiu-Jitsu we had a nice time you learned
something that was a good time H I'll
never lie to you my brother listen
regrets I have I didn't get into this 10
years early I would have been complet
different human being I would have been
on TV 3 years ago because the T the
discipline from going and getting choked
and all that [__] it's amazing anything
any martial art [__] helps you I've
always told you an hour a day three days
a week from all your [__] [__]
you could be broke so don't [__] me
you could be flat broke and go to a park
and do jumping jacks situps and push-ups
leave your phone in the
call an hour three days a week
I get up now early I get up at 4:30 you
think I want to get up at 4:30 I get up
I have a little coffee I pee I feed the
cats I clean the little
boxes and I got an hour and a half by
myself that is priceless in this world
to just collect your thoughts I ain't
lying to you I go on that balcony I hit
that pipe two times to get the blood
going B little [__] I get a pen I get
my
glasses and I [__] write in the
mornings now for an hour hour and a half
Denzel once said that any man who
[__] could laugh cry smile in one day
it's a good day somebody said that some
actors said that which makes sense you
know that's the same thing when you
write in the morning it's my hour and a
half I I always did it for years when I
was doing really well writing wise and
good jokes I was getting up really early
I was walking around a little bit with
insomnia some days I'd be tired but this
is what life's about this is what you
got to
do are we in the middle of an earthquake
no it's me tapping my leg I'm filled
with [__] uh Joy today you know what
I'm saying I'm excited cuz the lobster
truck's going to be there the baby's
going to be happy I'm going to be happy
I'm going to be here next Thursday I'm
good I got a good schedule I got to
spend some time with everybody it was a
good
summer we got to get uh you know
everything's good I can't complain I
wish uh KN on would and I hope everybody
else is doing well your kids are back in
school something really weird happened
let me break it down okay yeah morning I
woke up to my girl and commandant and
[__] Lieutenant of death ooky spooky
and then the main man himself talking L
they were going back and forth about an
individual had said something about me
in the podcast or something like that
you know what folks I just want you to
know something and this is cuz when Lee
told me and I was figuring it out I
giggled cuz I want you guys to know one
thing that these dudes half of these
people they walk around they hug they do
this but half of them look at you in
weird ways man they're not really trust
me what I'm listen I I got into this for
tons of reasons Lee but the main reason
because I read that book Lenny Bruce
wrote about doing comedy in New York and
he lived with a stripper and he went
back to his to the Chelsea Hotel and he
shot heroin and he barely made a living
but he paid his rent he ate he shot
herin he got his dick sucked when I was
30 that's what I was looking to do
comedy was the easiest path to
resistance I get when you go to the
elliptical and you don't use the handles
now it's the easiest path to resistance
all I did was that was go the easiest
path to resistance I was not going to
[__] put 5 years of my life to be an
electrician I was not going to do all
these things I tried which I liked I
still think about doing electricity now
I feel like being an apprentice at a
company two days a week and hanging
lights and [__] you know I'm an [__]
dog anything that I could smoke weed and
be left alone I would have sell at is it
good to smoke we didn't be around
electricity I did it for [__] 2 years
I loved it because I'm alone I'm I got
the Walkman onine I got my little
electricity belt I got my [__] uh the
the screws with the fours I got my my
screw drivers I got my drill I got my
lights already set I got my little
ladder I make two holes I pop an anchor
I boom boom I hang the lights I drill it
I put the shield up I take the wrapper
off you know you could do let's say
you're working on a building like this
each office is the same like so I come
in here and oh you got to hang over head
lights this is a week of work I do two
three offices a day I set two or three
of them up with wir and then I come back
with a scaffold Bam Bam that's what I
did you could depend on me you could I
could be there at 8:05 and you could go
Joey go and I'd be a [__] [__] and
do this little work I could handle that
so how old were you when you started
elri like how old would you had to be if
you wanted to wait five years I would
have been 25 like an [__] at 25 I
would have been a because you start as
an apprentice uh residential for two
years and then you have to get another
license at the time that's what it
was and what really crushed my career as
an electrician I loved it and I was
excelling at it I knew how to bend pipe
already how to make horseshoes I knew a
lot of [__] about electricity a lot of
people at my level wouldn't have known I
feel like the electricians right now
being like yeah but I took the course
from the electrical inspector and Aspen
so the final project to pass is you got
to go wire a house with
from
scratch damn so there's like three
houses and you and two other students
got to go in there you got an A or a b
or you fail and we got a name and he
went to all three of us and he goes
listen these guys don't even get it if
you want call me and I'll get your jobs
and I called them and they got me a
[__] job like that for like eight
bucks an hour within 3 weeks I had to
attend because they figured out that any
job I was on was going to get
passed so every time they had a big job
they go Joey come on we're giving you a
raise work on this job little did I know
they were using me because the
electrical inspector came and give me a
hug he correct me and he go b boom pass
are you [__] who the [__] do you think
you're dealing with Lisa some [__]
novice from the other [__] side I've
been telling you this [__] for
years you always had it in it's like the
Chinese restaurant all over
again oh leis yeah you always got to you
always got to pay a
get a taste what he was to have to get a
taste I was I wasn't getting no that
would give me a taste because they knew
that [__] I knew the dude who
inspected who's better than Uncle J and
then I took that taste of
Jager I call this Jager electric one
night I go listen this what's going on
they giving me this but I'm goomas with
the [__] this guy so any job I'm on
it's passed he just comes corrects it
and passes me and they're like when do
you want to start what are you doing
tomorrow morning at 8:00 pick me up at
Snowman and they're like pick you I'll
be there they bring coffee I know
people and they [__] come up pick me
up and they were good they were good to
me and then I went to Jersey like an
[__] I tell you what killed my
electrical career what hobok in New
Jersey CU I was making 12 15 an hour at
Aspen getting picked up lunch was being
bought for me I went to Hoboken they're
like what Ohio you and a heartbeat but
they wanted to start me at eight bucks
an hour and it was basically laboring
going underneath and taking out rewiring
and going under under the buildings
where rats were and scorpions and
bodies [__] you you have no idea when
you got to go I forget what what it's
called you got to do that as an
apprentice yeah that's what you do you
got to go under the [__] house and
set up wiring there's skunks under there
there's raccoons there's dead animals
there's rats it's a [__] nightmare
when you when you move you probably have
to start at the bottom again oh yeah no
no no that but this was like they wanted
me to start way way way way way deep in
the murky Waters of the underworld I
ain't going to lie to nobody I had done
that for about 8 months but then like
anything else I moved up to Wi and
bathrooms and in those days and Aspen
the hot thing was if he knew how to H
how to wire electric towel
warmers that was the big thing in Asen
at the time like like you know like uber
is now like if you wanted to be cool in
Asen you hadn't had an electric tow warm
and so when people came over the towels
were warm s nice and guess who knew how
to wire those things uncle Jo like a
[__] you know what I'm saying
I'm in a mood to crack my fingers today
youever in that mood and [__] some
Cubans do
this but I'm in the mood to snap my
fingers let's get the [__] out of here I
got to take two steps to the rear and
get out of here oh [__] what
happened what the [__] happened all
right the ice house tomorrow night
[__] Vegas uh next week the CD uh
what's the name of the place the the
oh Jesus Christ South Point the South
Point Hotel and you can get room and
show package deals if you call them so
do it a week after that I'm in New York
City at the Gotham Comedy Club oh [__]
all right here we go let's this a shut
this is going to be death on two legs
all right for you people who know if you
don't know now you know when we [__]
make it happen here like this morning I
went to jiu I didn't give nothing to Lee
the first time it's always I got my on
in the bag next time I go I'll take a
picture and [__] send it to you guys
always little shroom Tech before I get
on the mats or I lift weights just
because I'm a fat [__] and I want that
extra energy so I could my my workout
could last a little longer shroom Tech
is the one I work with in hemp Force
Protein that's what I work with on a
full-time level I go on cycles of the uh
Alpha Brain don't worry about it it
works I'm just St to the [__] gills
you people are looking at me like Joey
why you stuttering why because we Dro
some [__] Edibles of death I've been
smoking Reef I did the Periscope this
morning what Periscope Periscope
whatever the [__] it is and he the truck
driver had Periscope The Who that truck
driver what truck driver with the
15-year-old wife oh he was disgusting he
he has the pisc that was the creepiest
[__] thing ever I no one said like
hey man what happened here in those days
whatever you did nobody knew nothing you
could you could be married to a goat as
long as you paid your taxes in were nice
[__] it leave him alone who cares but
gameer so anyway h.com for all your
[__] supplement needs
there're it's a great product I tell you
[__] constantly whether it's
the Alpha Brain the shroom Tech the hemp
Force protein this is the [__] I know
about you want to try the te the
testosterone boost you want to try the
TCT oil all that stuff is available for
you go read up about it you're going to
[__] love it and it's just an intro
just to let you know how much I love you
I'm going to give you 10% off right off
the back because that's how Uncle Joey
Rose I'm not here to hold it on to
myself and whatever 10% off goes to you
go to the box and press in church boom
CH you are CH and get 10% off your first
order of Honor I ain't [__] around
with you this [__] [__] works you're
going to [__] love it try that shroom
let's say you flying let's say you hang
out with [__] up people you smoke
crack get the
shroom get the shroom Teck uh immune
let's say you suck on a pipe let's say
you're a female you suck 10 dicks a week
you don't want to get sick one of them
[__] somebody with the flu there you are
coughing you know it's tough to make a
living when you're coughing try room
Tech immune there you go go to on it and
press
in
church church CH Ur CH and get 10% off
you bad [__] maybe got reab
with the with the you what I what is
wrong with get the on it and then go to
rehab listen why you got to mention
people rehab people going to AA
meetings what the [__] is this [__] what
I got
10 got [__] problem
I got problems lis listen we all know
how sexy confidence can be all right and
that confidence is being [__]
comfortable if I had my nuts or my
underwear up my ass and [__] I'd walk in
here and I wouldn't feel as good you
could see it on my face just something
wrong with Joey he's either constipated
he's having a bad day but now you know
why I'm comfortable cuz I got me on
onu I had my [__] meundies on all
that type of activity because I don't
want [__] to happen I don't want nuts to
fall out I'm confident I still wear my
tidy whes from time I got a nice suit on
or something you got to wear the Tidy
whes I got to go old school to drop it
on these youngsters but when I'm doing
activity when I'm climbing I'm doing
what the [__] I do jumping you know you
know I
parachute this [__] [__] almost fell
over speaking of parachuting this
[__] Momo almost fell over here uh
what's I talking me listen why [__] with
you all right they got a complete line
of women's and Men's Under where comfy
is all hell I ain't even I wish I was
lying to you guys they got shorts they
got great t-shirts did you see I had the
meand t-shirt on Gray light you can wear
it underneath [__] tremendous
comfortable as [__] you understand me
that's what meand has they're [__]
comfortable as [__] but hey don't you
don't believe me go to me ones.com right
now look at the great selection of men
and women's clothing they have but focus
on those underwear guy that bad
[__] your bulge comes up your
nut sack stays dry it's a [__]
tremendous product I wouldn't kid you
right now I wear them 90% of the time I
I have them on right no I don't have
them on today I'm going commando cuz
it's 104° let the ball sweat go where
the ball sweat go anyway do me a favor
go to meundies.com right now and press
in Joey boom and get 20% off your order
and free shipping in Canada and the
United States it also let me tell you
something else modor is pronounced modor
me is made from modor a fabric that's
twice as soft as cotton that's why
they're so nice twice as soft as
whatever underwear you're wearing right
[__] now that's what I'm trying to
tell you and that's what it says in the
script I'm just [__] telling you how
I feel that's what they're telling you
to tell you I'm telling you before they
[__] told you how's that for yourself
go to meundies.com right now and get 10%
off 20% 20% off your first order and
free shipping to Canada and the United
States thank you for correcting me
that's the first Jew will give you 10%
more of anything you know what I'm
saying if this was his company you
wouldn't get [__] guts let me ask you
something you walk into a grocery store
and you find you find an AIS of snacks
what the [__] awesome right imagine you
didn't have these leave the couch you go
you get these chips they all taste like
[__] dick do me a favor you want to
get healthy nutritious snacks
pre-portion portion you could close them
and open them when you want go to
naturebox.com right now NatureBox off
offers a complete delicious nutritious
snacks whether it's the black uh the
black and pepper lentils whether it's
the jalapeno cashews
oh my God whether it's the jalapeno
popcorn whether it's the sesame sticks
listen every week they get better and
better did I not give you your box no
Jesus [__] I never get my Bo I
thought I gave you your box and [__] you
always said that and then maybe I get
like a weird one N I thought I sent I
gave your address they [__] up again I
got to talk to Nature Box you know what
I'm saying nature box is what snacks are
on my counter right now and I'm even you
know my baby love to death those uh salt
and pepper lentils oh my God I knew she
just took the whole bag from me the
jalapeno cashews they went down the
sarashi cashews went down have you tried
like the aago crisp things not yet
they're so good oh they're so good oh my
God Che better they're like fancy
cheeses but healthier and delicious
listen guys they're all all out they got
granola they got great snacks but don't
want go to naturebox.com right now and
put in go to Nature naturebox.com jooy
and look at the great selection of
snacks and uh meals that no they got no
meals why you looking at me all weird
that's the next one you're confusing me
Le no go to naturebox.com right now Joey
SL jooy and get your and take a look at
the nutritious delicious snacks that
they have available to you right now go
to
naturebox.com jooy and pressing what Le
nothing you know what the press Lee
don't be lying to me no seriously
naturebox.com right now/ Joey SL Joey
tremendous nutritious delicious snacks
delivered right to your door and you can
personally IE your own snacks all right
this is the one that's uh I've been
getting great reviews from people been
emailing me thanking me they're like
Joey how did you find out about
this uh you know what the [__] is going
on here I just had it here why are they
lying to me for did you take the the the
copy formula
no anyway let me let me talk to you
people from the heart because this has
come to my house a couple times and I
really enjoyed them Blue Apron is a
service that they deliver pre-portion
uncooked meals delivered right to your
house they come in a box with Lum fo
around them with a nice little they're
sealed you take it out they have the
recipes they send you and they have the
exact amount of what you're going to add
to each recipe how to cook it what
temperature whether you bake it cut it
everything comes cut I mean they send
you a cucumber the Cucumber comes hold
they expect you to cut it don't be that
lazy no but it's cool because a lot of
times like when you're cooking for like
one or two people and you want to make a
whole recipe you have to go buy a a
spice you don't have you use it twice
and then it just sits there so they send
you all all all everything to the dot on
that thing and you add it dute whatever
the hell you want to do you put it in
there the nutritious the calories the
protein I mean everything's in there
measured for you you know how many times
you come home you got to stop at the
store and then you got to park the car
walk in Stand online once you're online
you forgot the pepper deck now you got
to walk back get online by the time you
get home you're tired ah scratch that
with blue apron you get home the meal's
already brought in your kid brought it
in you bring it into the thing you go to
the bathroom you take a pee you wash
your hands you take off your skirt
whether you got pants on let's say
you're a guy whoever [__] Cooks in
the house you go back there you open up
the box you get the skillet or the
boiler whatever it calls for you to make
and boom you make delicious nutritious
dinners right there available to you
they got a two-person plan and they got
a family plan let me tell you what the
two person plan had this week they had
uh salmon burgers alioli and they had
mushroom rot calzon can you imagine
getting home make a mushroom orone
that's a two people dinner let's say you
got a date on Wednesday night you got a
couple of those boxes send over you cook
it up with a it makes everything a lot
easier I want to sign up for but eat
both of those [__] you I eat the whole
thing then for the family plan you had
barbecue roast pork and you had crispy
cod sandwiches little things over like a
little post law oh my God that's the
family plan and all this it's even
cheaper if you buy it and I'm telling
you right now it's pennies cheaper but
don't believe me do me a favor go to
blueapron.com and press in Joey and get
how many meals two two meals for free on
them blue aon.com you will not be sorry
you're busy you don't really have time
to go shopping give blue Apon a try
they're giving you two free meals what
are they press in Joey that's it ug gots
that's it it's a rep people I about a
shout out to H it me on these
naturebox.com and Blue Apron I want to
send them some love and thank you for
sponsoring the show as always I want to
thank my May Man Lee sayat for putting
it together I'm doing these uh flying
you radio Callin shows about topics so
if uh I just did one about religion so
people want to go listen to it I
appreciate it all right any other
calling topics you want to do about [__]
Lia why you giving me crap for no reason
calling right now who hey
anybody
so wait ice house and then
Vegas okay all right don't forget about
me people I love you guys thank you for
supporting the church don't forget next
week I'm doing the DVD Las Vegas then
it's New York [__] City Gotham Comedy
Club 11:45 for the creepers the people
who don't hang out with people that go
to church 1145 you know what I'm saying
you got to come heavy duty like I said
on the [__] Fitz podcast if you got
44 these you cannot be a Christian you
know what I'm saying shut the window
part three [__] it I love you guys stay
black this show is brought to you by
Blue Apron